that last Knicks team you played on was
were you on the team when the linsanity
[__] happened absolutely
what was that like to be crazy [__] it
was the craziest [__] ever dude because
it was kind
of cocker was next to Jeremy Lin's oh so
it was cracking after those games not it
was no it wasn't cracking it was like my
locker is here Jeremy Jeremy Lynn Locker
is here and there's a 150 media in the
lock that's what I mean
not cracking I you have to leave you
have to hey man hold on let me get my
[__] let me let me go change in the in
the regular bathroom in the bathroom
star hey dude Jeremy Lynn had the whole
team changing in the [__] shower
wherever we could you couldn't be in
that locker room they had to move him
from the locker room and every interview
he had was a press conference
crazy it was like 150 people every time
he had to get interviewed he couldn't do
it in the locker room because it'd be
too many people in the locker locker
room you couldn't change you couldn't
stretch you couldn't do [__] so they had
to like take him to another school was
Dan Tony coaching that team Dan Tony was
yeah it's crazy because I think like man
Dan Tony used to call Jeremy Lin Angels
in the Outfield
watch out cause I told them because I
Jeremy Lin was there to like help me get
back to planning so I needed another
week and so that's how he wind up
staying that week playing against bro uh
the Brooklyn Nets and then going on his
run
that's how he got his other 10 day
because I wasn't ready my back was still
[__] up and I was like so if you would
have been healthy we might not ever
should have never seen Jeremy Lynn
great there was like this thing because
mellow was injured at the time right
yeah he went on that run yeah because I
told mellow mellow was carrying the team
yeah Mella was carrying the team and he
was like you know we were struggling
dude we was like losing by six losing by
four and it was all due to we didn't
have a point guard that went downhill
because Mike Bibby was on the team right
on the team but Mike Bibby was [__] Mike
Bibby was towards the end of his career
for sure Tony Douglas was a point guard
but not really a point guard Iman
Shumpert was a rookie who was a shooting
Garden out of point guard working jump
on that team yeah so like with J.R Smith
on that two second time you played with
JR yes J.R Smith you played with him as
a rookie yeah he was my rookie yeah but
like his rookie year was uh the I feel
like that was the year I got traded to
Golden State yep yeah so I think it was
yep so you know played with him for like
a half a year yeah but he's you know
Swiss used to live with me oh yeah like
he lived with his parents in New Orleans
but like you know when he wanted to go
out and hang out I'm like I'm spend the
night at BD house we're gonna go to
practice so so it's just like my little
brother for life I was gonna say with
the Mellow Jeremy Len thing I remember
the national narrative was like uh you
know how's mellow gonna play with Jeremy
Lin when he comes back from being
healthy was there like any sort of like
ever any tension in the locker room
between that with that whole situation
uh it was some weird [__] going on
because
obviously like we riding a wave Super
Wave and and the linsanity wave is just
it mellow out remember it was injured
when he when he went on that run yeah
yeah he gonna run we went like five six
in a row
mellow comeback
but lamello come back
Jeremy Lin is the biggest star in the
world [__] [__] New York in the world
[__] New York the world bro for sure
the world he's the he has literally went
from like nobody to the face of the NBA
and you gotta remember also I feel like
we are just transitioning out of the
whole lockout remember the lockout
squeeze so we're about a year and a half
or maybe two and a half years in so it's
like the league is still needing a thing
to happen man when that thing happened
it was like Melo came back and Jeremy
Lin was so big he was bigger than mellow
mm-hmm media wise yeah and so it did
create a little like
this [__] is not real like we can't we
can't live in this is sustainable or not
yeah bro we can't live in this but like
we should be living in it but I think
like it started to create
um
like tension in the in our in the way we
play
um
I feel like because it's still mellow
teams mellow is still the dog you know
what I mean mellow is still our ghost
was Amari on the team yet Amari was on
the team he was injured right Amari was
injured and coming back but remember it
was omari's team first yeah Mari had
that Amari first year when he was on it
had a rocket when he had that first year
with the Knicks he had it rocking
he had it rocking another injury another
I mean yeah think about that like like
now imagine Amar'e Stoudemire or what if
why why would I sit here and be
questioning myself crazy you got people
like you know Amar'e Stoudemire Brandon
Roy yeah Brandon Roy Penny Hardaway
Grant Hill Grant Hill would have might
be might probably be the top 10 player
ever Sean Livingston John Livingston
like bro we ain't even get to see the
real Sean living I mean we saw it we saw
him he had a great career I saw him have
an incredible career but you didn't see
what could have been you know what I
mean but you can't live on that [__] was
Mike D'Antoni
um because I'm a Suns fan so obviously I
have a place in my heart for Him how was
he like to to play with was it was he
doing this seven seconds or less [__]
with you guys uh Mike and Antoni was as
a coach was cool yeah no defense did he
not give a [__] about defenses we're
talking about no defense okay okay he
wasn't talking about he wasn't talking
about it yeah he ain't talking about no
defense just seven seconds or less your
offense yeah no it wasn't so much seven
of seconds it was just more so like he
needed
his point guard to go north south yep
and as talented as you were being able
to go north south his point guard was
the most integral part of the of the
offense because anytime a point guard
goes downhill the whole Lane the whole
defense yeah because you got Shooters
you got Shooters surrounding yeah and
then if the big man is setting a pick
you really playing two on two basketball
if they stay at home so like that's why
Steve Nash was so good you know Chris
Duhan had 31 assists with uh on the
Knicks Duhan was a [__] I remember
having a fantasy basketball one year and
his system in in dantoni's system if
you're a point guard and you go north
that's why Jeremy Lin was so successful
because at the time he could penetrate
that pain man he just put his hand down
drive right and go and he's not bad he
can make plays at The Rim he can finish
he's a bigger guard you know what I mean
but if you go downhill even if you get
in trouble somebody's open facts and so
like that's kind of like
the dantoni system that's why I went to
the Knicks you know at the end of the
day because I was like damn if I can get
right yeah right I can I can Steve Nash
this [__] you know what I mean yeah hell
yeah but it's just like I [__] my [__]
up I came in in the next not thinking
I'll be able to walk again was Isaiah
Thomas the GM at the time no uh it was
uh Glenn Grunwald okay shout out to
Isaiah Thomas yeah very scared that he's
gonna take over the sun's Jam position
we'll see oh that could be dope I don't
know would it be we'll see that's real
tight with Matt ish beer so yeah that'll
be dope we'll see I'm just liking I'm
like I think James Jones is there now
yeah James is great yeah James
Jones is cool